hallo ihr lieben ich habe mir gedacht
die banana split orte die kamen so gut
bei euch an lasse ich mir noch mal etwas
mit bananen einfallen und ich habe heute
etwas für euch dass es novak also der
ofen bleibt aus und es ist total
raffiniert also wenn ihr das serviert
wenn eure gäste sein
wow was ist das denn richtig cool ich
zeig euch jetzt zuallererst den teilchen
anzusprechen
ich sage euch gleich warum aber dafür
benötigen wir folgen mit zwei zutaten
zum einen sind das diese löffelbiskuits
und zum anderen etwas milch wichtig für
den nächsten schritt ist dass ihr euch
ein großes schneidebrett nimmt oder
irgendwas was groß ist reicht ist und in
euren kühlschrank passt es ist auch ganz
wichtig und darüber gibt ihr zweimal
frischhaltefolie so dass sie eine
richtig schöne lange fläche habt jetzt
nehmen wir uns unseren löffelbiskuits
drucken sie für eine sekunde in die
milch und geben sie dann mit der zucker
seite nach unten auf unser schneidebrett
[Musik]
sobald ihr eine reihe vollständig habe
mit zwölf löffelbiskuits gibt ihr die
anderen zwölf würfe biscuits eine reihe
darunter
[Musik]
so fertig und jetzt geben wir
frischhaltefolie darüber und
anschließend kommt das in den
kühlschrank für mindestens zweieinhalb
bis drei stunden und dann zeige ich euch
wie es weitergeht
[Musik]
und nach der zeit der löffel biscuits
machen wir weiter mit unserer füllung
also der creme und dafür zeige ich euch
jetzt die zutaten zum einen benötigen
wir natürlich beim namen außerdem kalte
schlagsahne magerquark mascarpone
puderzucker ein paar schoko drops und
sahne stand mittel für die creme
verwende ich jetzt die küchenmaschine
ihr könnt natürlich auch euer
handrührgerät verwenden und ich mache
das immer gerne so dass ich mascarpone
und magerquark zusammen mit sahne und
puderzucker in die schüssel geben und
anschließend schreie ich das so ein
bisschen etwa eine halbe minute
dass sich das verbindet und dann zeige
ich euch wie es weitergeht
[Musik]
nach etwa 30 sekunden geben wir unser
seine stand mit hin zu schlagen das
schön auf höchster stufe und dann merkt
schon dass die sahne steif mir richtig
schöne feste creme erhalte
[Musik]
so nach ein bis zwei minuten ist die
creme auch schon fertig jetzt gebe ich
noch die schoko drops hinein
ihr könnt natürlich statt der schoko
drops auch ganz andere sachen rein tun
wie zum beispiel was gibt's denn da
haben sie kokosraspeln passen ganz gut
zu bananen oder was ich auch finde
himbeeren himbeeren und bananen sind
eine tolle mischung also gerne
tiefkühlware eingeben aber ich glaube
heute bei den schoko drops
[Musik]
jetzt wird die torte nur noch
zusammengestellt dafür ziehe ich
zuallererst die obere frischhaltefolie
von löffelbiskuits und dann gehen wir
unsere creme darauf wichtig ist dass
hier oben und unten so ungefähr zwei
zentimeter freilauf wir später richtig
schön aufwickeln können
[Musik]
sobald die creme verstrichen habt gebt
ihr bananen drauf auf das untere drittel
und ich mag es über wenn die bananen
schon richtig schön braun sind wie seht
ihr das denn das wird nicht mehr sehr
trist war spalten sich ja wirklich die
geister na dann lieber wenn so braun bin
ein bisschen süße oder möglich wenn ihr
noch richtig grün sind ich weiß ja gar
nicht sondern es kommt immer darauf an
wie groß die bananen ich brauche jetzt
zweieinhalb gibt es jetzt hier wie
gesagt auch das untere drittel
und dann wollen wir das ganze ein
[Musik]
und die bananen rolle ist eigentlich
schon fertig jetzt fehlt nur noch die
deko dafür habe ich mir ein bisschen von
der krim zur seite gegeben und in eine
ganz große stern twittern damit auch die
schoko drucks durch passen und jetzt
werde ich sie noch abschließend
dekorieren
[Musik]
das besondere an der bananen rolle ist
dass sie so schön weich ist die löffel
mit skizzen richtig schön soft natürlich
könnt ihr auch in andere flüssigkeiten
trinken gerne auch kaffee aber ich habe
heute mein kinderfreundlich und wie
schmeckt wunderbar mit diesen schoko
drops dazwischen hat man so ein richtig
schön krank noch und falls ihr das ganze
am vortag zubereiten möchte funktioniert
auch wunderbar ich schreibe euch wie
immer die genauen zutaten hier unten in
der infobox macht es gerne nach
hinterlasst dem video einen deutlichen
nach oben und ein abo dann verfasst ja
auch nichts berg und im anschluss
verlinke ich euch auch noch die banana
split heute die so gut deutsch ankam da
habe ich auch über instagram ganz viele
fotos von euch bekommt macht es gerne
auch wieder ich freue mich immer sehr
eure fotos anzuschauen und freue mich
wenn ihr beim nächsten mal auch wieder
dabei zeit auf wiedersehen tschüs
[Musik]